- Is working in consulting glamorous?
This is the topic that I
wanna talk about today.
Many people seem to believe
that working in consulting
and especially at an MBB consulting firm,
so McKinsey, BCG, Bain,
is a work that is attached
to a certain lifestyle,
to a glamorous lifestyle indeed.
Today I'm going to discuss exactly this,
so welcome to another coffee break
here on my channel, Firm Learning.
My name is Heinrich.
I'm a former McKinsey consultant.
I spent six years with the firm
and now I'm in a CTO position
at a German retailer.
And so before I jump
into the glamorous aspect
of the life of a consultant,
I first of all wanna give
credits to this other video
from RocketBlocks that
I took as inspiration
and then also give two
important caveats to this video.
And the first is that
the situation changes
quite significantly,
not only firm by firm,
but also among the different
geographies and countries.
So to better understand what
is possible in your location
and your country,
make sure that you do talk
to some local consultants
to really understand this.
And the second caveat that I
wanna give is that this video
is not talking about one specific firm,
but rather describing the
situation at MBB firms,
so McKinsey, BCG, Bain.
Another thing I just wanna be
clear on is that, of course,
if you work in consulting,
you do not do it just for
these glamorous aspects.
Trust me that you will not be happy,
you will not be satisfied with your job
if this is your main motivation.
But of course, this
might be a little extra,
this might be a little plus
that just makes your life
a little bit more comfortable.
And of course, to some extent,
this is also at least part of the appeal
of joining one of these firms.
In the very end of the video,
we'll talk about another
very important topic.
And this is why, even though
the life can be glamorous
in all these ways, in
practice, in reality,
often these things are not possible.
Often, you cannot really make
use of all of these things.
So watch until the end for
this very important aspect
just to get the full
picture, the whole picture,
to what extent the life of a consultant
is really glamorous.
So let's get started.
Let's start with travel.
And one of the aspects that
for sure most people find
most appealing is the
airline status that you get.
For sure, with your national
airline, but with many others,
you will collect status.
Almost every consultant I
know who works at an MBB firm
has a Senator status with
the German Lufthansa,
which corresponds to Star
Alliance Gold status.
I even know a couple of
people who have a HON status
at the German Lufthansa.
And for those of you who
do not know what that is,
it's just a status that gives you access
to insane benefits.
If you're interested in that,
check out the Lufthansa page
to understand this better.
And of course, what's
also important to say
is that this video will
especially focus on the situation
how it was until 2019.
So before this new
situation in 2020 evolved,
which of course, severely
impacts many of the things
that we are going to talk about.
So this airline status is great.
It gives you access to lots of lounges.
This gives you access
to priority boarding.
You collect lots of points.
Another nice benefit is
that you will get access
to business class travel,
not only on long-haul flights,
but at least for some
offices, for some firms,
even on short domestic flights.
This is, of course, a perk
that is very comfortable,
especially given that
you will fly quite a lot,
in most countries at least.
Similar to the airlines is the hotels.
Here just have a collection
of some of the bonus cards
that I collected over the last years.
Of course, there were many more
because most of them are digital nowadays.
But it is true that you do get access
to lots of nice hotels.
You will stay in Hyatts, in Ritz Carltons,
in Ws and all these nice Starwood hotels.
And of course, it does make a difference,
if you really work super late,
if you really sit in the team
room until after midnight,
if then at least you come to a nice hotel.
At least, I often felt that
this did increase team morale.
So this is one of these nice perks
and these nice benefits
of working in consulting.
Next point on travel is cars.
So pretty much wherever you go,
you can pretty much always take the taxi.
You never need to take public transport.
And if you do need a rental car,
you often get access to nice cars,
which might make your
life easier this way.
Next point is team activities.
The one thing, of course, to
talk about is team dinners.
So often after some nice
milestones in the project,
the partner will invite the whole team
to a nice, very upscale restaurant,
often also Michelin-star restaurants.
Depending on what city
and area you are in,
you might eat in some of
the nicest restaurants
of the country.
It's, of course, great to
have access to this nice food,
especially if you are a foodie
and appreciate it a lot.
But besides dinners, often
you have also different
other types of offsite activities
where your team, your
office, or maybe some groups
within the office meet for a weekend
or for some days throughout the week
to discuss some topics,
just have a offsite,
take some days off your regular work.
Again, these are often great locations
with great benefits, great activities,
often nice night outs
afterwards in the evening.
These are experiences where
you can form great memories
and build some lasting friendships also
beyond your daily job as a consultant.
The next area I wanna talk
about is the compensation,
other benefits, that you
will get as a consultant.
It is no secret that as an MBB consultant,
you will earn very decent salaries.
And these high salaries, of course,
open up possibilities for you.
You will be able to afford nicer things,
maybe a nicer, larger flat,
and whatever else you might fancy.
Of course, if you are a regular
watcher of this channel,
you do know that I advocate
not spending your whole money
but rather saving.
I made a whole video
about why I do believe
it is so crucial to get
your savings rate high
as a consultant.
I will link it somewhere
above here, so check it out
to learn more about my
thinking on this topic.
Similar to that is the car policies.
So most MBB firms in
most locations do offer
a quite attractive car policy.
So this means that even
as a junior consultant,
you will get access to nice cars.
And the more senior you become,
the larger the car that you could get.
So here again, personally,
I did not make use
of this car policy.
I decided not to take a company car.
Often, then there are some
alternatives you can choose from
if you decide not to take it.
For me, again, in this period of saving,
the reason was to avoid the taxes
that you do need to pay if you get a car.
But if you decide that you
wanna get a car anyway,
of course, the company car
policy is often very attractive
and can get you access
to some very nice cars.
So these are the reasons
that in my perception
most contribute to this
maybe glamorous lifestyle
that you might get in such
an MBB consulting firm
in McKinsey, BCG or Bain.
Of course, these things are subjective.
So whether you do actually
perceive these things
to be glamorous, of course,
depends on your very personal opinion.
And of course, there is
also an argument to be made
that these things that might
be perceived as glamorous
are the very same things that contribute
to the bad lifestyle,
that contribute to you spending
lots of time away from home.
And of course, there's a
good argument to be made
that there's nothing more luxurious,
nothing more glamorous,
to spending time at home,
spending time with your family,
and I completely understand
that and completely see
where you're coming from if
this is what your opinion is.
But in the beginning I said that often,
you actually cannot
really make use of this.
I believe this is really
an important point
that you need to be aware of if you decide
to get into consulting
and maybe you believe
that you will have all
these benefits and perks.
And this reason is that often your project
actually does not take place
in one of these large cities
where you have these nice
hotels, nice airports.
So it does happen that
your project is in a city
that's very small somewhere
in the middle of nowhere.
Then the logistics are quite
complicated to get there.
Often in these areas, there
just aren't any nice hotels.
You just need to take
whatever hotel is available.
And the airport might be so small
that you actually just cannot
fly there business class
because there are only low-cost carriers.
So all of this is part of the reality
of being a consultant as well.
And again, what I believe
is also very important
to clearly say is that the
smaller the consulting firm is
that you work for,
so if you work for tier two
or tier three consulting firm,
and also if you work for Big
4 firm or a boutique firm,
these glamorous aspects often go away.
So with these firms, you
will often not be able
to fly business class.
These firms will often allow
you only to stay in hotel
one or two tiers below the
hotels that I was talking about.
So be aware that the firm that you join
will significantly impact your abilities
to tap into all these perks.
So what does my life look like now?
The truth is now that
I'm out of consulting
for about a year, most of
my statuses have expired.
I'm not having access
to all of these things.
Now personally, I take the bicycle.
I still don't have a car
and I usually take the train
instead of a plane.
And I must say that while
I, of course, enjoyed
all these nice perks while
I still lived in consulting,
I still also feel pretty
good given that now all
of these things have
been taken away from me.
This is, I believe, also
an important takeaway
out of all of this.
So while all of this, of course, is nice,
this is by no means necessary
and I do not really think
that this really improved
the quality of my life.
So let me know your
opinion in the comments.
Are you intrigued by these
glamorous aspects of consulting?
Do you find these things glamorous at all?
What is your opinion on this topic?
Leave me a comment below
in the comments section.
I will reply to every single comment.
And as you know, whenever
you leave a comment,
this also helps me with
the YouTube systems.
So every comment is much appreciated.
As always, if you took any
value out of this video at all,
please hit the Like button
for the YouTube algorithm
and also hit the Subscribe
button to stay up-to-date
on all my content.
If you want to see even more from me,
also follow me on my Instagram.
My handle is @firmlearning.
I also have a mailing list.
You can find a signup link to that below
in the video description.
And also feel free to reach out to me
and follow me on LinkedIn.
Again, the link is in
the video description.
And I wanna say thank
you to all the members
of Firm Learning.
Everyone of you is really
contributing to the cause
of this channel.
I very much appreciate your support.
If you are thinking about
becoming a member as well,
just hit the Join button
next to the Subscribe button
to learn about all the
benefits that you get.
So now I wanna say thank
you, thank you very much
if you watched until the end.
If you did watch until the end,
just leave me a comment below
just that I know that you did.
And for the rest of you guys,
I release weekly videos
every single Saturday,
so looking forward to next week's video.
See you then.
Until then, good weekend,
great Christmas holidays
to all of you, bye bye, Heinrich here.